one two
one one two one two
one two one one one two
one two one one two check one
one two
i think everything's working hi
i can explain
i can't explain how the intro went with
me going one and two other than that i
was trying to make sure that the audio
levels were good but i can explain what
is in the thumbnail um i can explain
that real good and i'll explain in just
a moment i will tell you about it it
will be incredible when i tell you about
it my explanation will be so good you
will love it and appreciate it and
understand my perspective on what i'm
trying to explain to you
one two one two
hi yes
um
it has been a long time since i did a
live stream uh it has been a long long
time and i thought no better way to get
all of this out in the open
than on a live stream to you guys to you
guys i really appreciate you i
appreciate you being here and your your
future understanding for
my
circumstances and the situation that i
find myself in
and when you hear the explanation that
i'm going to give you oh
oh you're going to just oh you're just
going to understand and you're going to
appreciate you're going to appreciate
and understand you're going to
you're going to appreciate i can't
believe it you know i can't believe how
well you're going to understand my
perspective on why i have this
possession in my possession
so
um
yeah if you haven't seen the thumbnail
great that's good honestly you don't
need context context is not important
actually context is very important
especially to the explanation that i'm
about to give you about this thing that
i'm going to uh reveal to you
um
hi yes hello everybody hi oh thank you
all members i know i haven't done a
member mixer in a long long time
i'm getting back into the swing of
things it's been incredibly busy uh
hence why i wanted to do a live stream
to update you find people on what's
going on in my life and what i've been
up to in all this time because i have
i've been unbelievably busy i've been
more busy than i've ever been and this
past like seven months has been just a
constant sprint and i know i said that i
was like i'm coming home and
everything's gonna be back to normal and
no no it was not but i'm getting better
i'm getting back to where i need to be
yes
hello hi
hello hello welcome appreciate you being
here are you ready for the explanation
i'm going to explain so good to you guys
so
i own
i don't own i have i'm not gonna own
suggests that i bought it and bought it
is not what i did i want to make that
very clear first out of the gate
it
was
gifted to me
it it it sailed in on a tumber cellar on
the the southern wind and it flew into
my house and it because it's so goddamn
heavy and huge it caused incredible
amount of damage um but
i have to angle the camera up for you
guys to properly appreciate this i just
need some extra height there we go that
that should be enough okay so just
hold on
hold on to your horses
okay so
i
hey
how you doing everybody
excuse where i'm grabbing it's not like
that it's not like that you guys are
assuming a lot of things right away i
haven't even gotten my explanation you
guys are assuming a lot of things you
guys are assuming a lot of things hey
hold on there was no judgment we all
promised that there would be no judgment
and you would understand and like you
would understand my circumstances with
which i have this so hold on your
judgment hold it keep it to yourselves
slow mode's on for a reason you got to
save your messages for when you really
want to put them out now i know what
this excuse me i know this looks like
i know what this looks like i know i
know what it looks like and you're right
good job you're so smart in uh your
ability to see and understand what your
eyes are perceiving um well done
this
is lady dimmitt rescue
and the reason that i have
lady dimitrescu in my house
is not because i chose it i want to be
well okay i accepted it
it's like a vampire right and she's like
big vampire lady isn't that how she's
known
but anyway so
like a vampire i accepted it and ever
since it's been
in my house she has been in my house
i don't know where i'm padding
there there all right so
before i get into the explanation which
is that's definitely forthcoming and
we'll be soon i i know you guys want to
get like a like an appreciable view
uh because this thing is life size
it's uh
it's um uh
that's not even all the way i can't
it's uh it's um pretty big
it's pretty huge
it's uh excuse where i'm grabbing i'm
sorry
i'm sorry so rude of me uh she's uh
she's a little limp
hang on
she's uh
she's big
so uh yeah she um
she's uh
almost as tall as i am okay so look
listen you guys are you guys are still
there's a lot of judgment happening and
we all promised that there wasn't gonna
be nearly as much judgment as there is
okay
so
this
was cursed upon me by one known as alex
tema otherwise known as hybrid wellness
otherwise known as my personal trainer
now why
why
my personal trainer
decided that it would be a good idea to
get me
a life-sized lady in the trescue body
pillow
i'm not 100 sure
uh
i don't really know and my god this has
been tough to hide from amy
she doesn't know a thing about it yeah i
mean it's obviously you can tell like
pretty hefty not easy to put away at a
moment's notice
not uh not the not the simplest thing
hang on let me get my camera back down
to human levels
and so um uh
yeah now now i have this
i i have this
and it's it's true to scale as far as i
know i don't really know how we would
prove that but it's apparently nine foot
six
and uh yeah it's um it's mine um
i don't know how to get rid of it
because i feel like if i put it in my
trash can
i just
the trash guy would have too many
questions and then i'd have to take out
the trash guy and then
that'd be just a cycle of punishment
that i don't want to deal with so i
guess
i'll hold on her
i guess
i suppose i shall but you know because
uh alex team of my personal trainer has
a youtube channel i have linked in the
description down below if you can go
tell them thank you for me from me
that i
appreciate and and
love
my gift that he got me
for everyone just walking in hi i can
explain
[Laughter]
i i where that's the thing like it's so
big it's so you don't understand how
hefty this thing is like i i hurt my
back the other day so you know my huge
muscles aren't as huge as they usually
would be but it's it's like
i don't know maybe like
it's like 20 25 pounds of pillow
it's a lot of pillow no not 25 pounds
i'm over us like 15 pounds it's like 15
pounds of pillow and that's a lot of
pillow and i don't have a lot of pillow
space
anyway so uh yeah i hope you accepted my
explanation of what is going on here
and i appreciate you're all
understanding me so perfectly
additionally this served a double
purpose ha gotcha you've been tricked
you were so distracted by lady
dimitrescu that you didn't even see the
subliminal messaging between the lines
you've been fooled you've been
bamboozled
i can't believe you fell for it anyway
uh while i was standing up i secretly
modeled
sean's new cloak line that i was
supposed to promote
yesterday
i
i got i was busy
and i hurt my back but now i've got you
it's all burned in your brain check it
out the new tactical line available at
cloakbrand.com you got guy
so you have to now you have to go check
it out cloakbrand.com you'll never get
away from it it's buried in your brain
now
it's like a lot of it's sold out and i i
should have
i should have mentioned it like days ago
anyway
so yeah i
it's really good it's really nice i do
like it a lot it's it's well made it's
good stuff i'm very happy with it um and
just like uh
i'm doing my part
promotionally i'm good at that i'm good
at that this is why people don't sponsor
me yeah um but also uh uh like this is a
live stream just so i can talk to you
guys because i haven't had a chance to
actually talk to you and update you and
all the different things that i've been
doing uh in the past few months
um where do i even begin
uh
yeah i announced
space in space with markiplier i haven't
been able to say those words i've been
so i even now i'm kind of hesitant like
can i say it i'm like yeah i can say it
it's out in the open everybody knows
about the trailer's been out so it's
like it's good it's good but i've been
working on that pretty much non-stop all
the post-production side of that has
been uh quite quite an ordeal um just
because it's huge and
like but it's been fun like it's been so
much fun i i'm so much
more excited about this one for you guys
to see than uh heist i mean not the
heist was bad now not that i wasn't
excited but just like oh i can't wait
for you guys to sink your teeth into
this one it's going to be great um not
sure when it's going to come out yet no
spoilers either i'm not going to talk
about it um and just like
yeah there's a trailer
oh yeah you didn't see the trailer uh
it's a teaser trailer more than anything
it was really just for the title so we
could get out there because i was so
afraid that i was just gonna
blab and spoil everything so i i like to
blab in the form of a trailer so that it
can have some kind of
you know aesthetic to it you know that'd
be nice um
why do i use weird wording i don't use
weird wording i use the way i talk
that i've learned
which i have
learned
it
pin it on my wall whatever i just got a
stab lady lady dimitrescu through the
heart right up against my wall just like
bam
yeah that would get rid of it now
definitely get rid of it uh yeah i know
i've been doing just a lot of that
a lot a lot of that a lot of working on
some other projects you know i'm
constantly like cycling other things
that we got going on
um and i just like
yeah i just
it's not a sex doll
it's not it's not a sex doll that's not
what that is
is that what you think that is that's
not it's a pillow it's just a pillow
don't read into it any more than that
that's not what it is look your mind is
in the gutter you need to get it out
into the
what do you call it are they still
gutters if they're on the roof
you need to get under the roof gutters
not the street gutters you got to get up
here in these gutters
[Music]
anyway it's not a sex doll
not a sex doll
not at all amy does not know about it
yet please do not tell amy
thank
alex for it but it is not
don't thank him for
a sex doll because that's not what it is
yeah i'm very sure i'm very 100 sure
yeah 100 very sure
so uh where was i talking about things
besides
lady dimitrescu over here am i
oh no my stream is crashing
i'm back now
hello again
kind of went unstable there for a little
bit i think i think the internet was
trying to shut me down for my weird
wording of saying things
uh
yes uh also
we are
mere
hours away from the anniversary of the
end of unisonis and uh yeah that is
something that has definitely been on my
radar uh the only thing i'll say is and
for you guys here who are live only is
um
you know how we like to
do things at the stroke of midnight
stroke of midnight
the strike of midnight stroke the stroke
of midnight
the stroke of mid
the stroke of midnight
how you say it
i have no idea
anyway
that's all i'll say that's all i'll say
about it that's all i'll say
stroke of midnight is that what it is
like stroke
stroke midnight when the clock strokes
when the clock strokes 12.
no i'm not having a stroke i'm fine i'm
100 fine
anyway that's all i'll say about that
you know i got nothing else to say you
know i am you know how i am all
secretive in the like very very
secretive about the things that i'm
doing and what i've got going on in my
life um
i have
no update on
edge of sleep yet i've got nothing and
you have nothing from me because i can't
say anything and i will not say anything
therefore you don't even know that i'm
even thinking about that so don't even
ask me about that because there's
nothing to know and there's nothing that
i can tell you to know so don't even
know anything about the thing that i'm
talking about
see the body feel good you guys are
insatiable
you guys are insatiable but all right
here there there she is there there she
is there she excuse my
my caress it's it's very very much
larger than you think it was it's
absolutely 100 much larger than you
think it was
yeah
so
uh i had some more important things to
talk about oh yeah distractible how dare
you how dare you have not listened to
distractible yet i haven't gotten a
promo for distractible out since like a
month and a half and i i'm feeling like
an itch for it i feel like i'm i feel
like i'm craving promoting distractible
to you guys so how dare you not have
done the thing that i tell you what is
that link down in the description oh
does that go to distractible available
on your feet all of your favorite
podcasting services oh there it is down
there so easy and free for you to listen
to we're giving our hearts and soul into
this free content for you and you're not
listening to it how dare you how dare
you ow my shoulder back how dare you
hurt my back shoulder it's your fault
because you didn't listen to
distractible you caused me pain
actually did hurt my shoulder just like
yesterday that's that's the unfortunate
thing i wasn't doing anything i was
literally not doing anything and i hurt
my back i i was standing at my desk and
all of a sudden i went like my back kind
of hurts and then through the rest of
the day like i almost became immobile
from
from the amount of like ouchies you know
what i mean so i don't know but it's not
me hurting myself it's you causing me to
hurt myself therefore you're to blame
and the only thing that'll cure it is is
more people listening to distractible
have you seen them have you listened to
the most recent episode it's pretty good
oh i'm feeling better already some
people literally oh no wait no some
people didn't listen to it ass hurt more
anyway
um
yeah i know no
yeah yeah
no no i feel it i feel it literally i i
don't understand how i can do absolutely
nothing
and hurt my
it's like in my shoulder blade i i've
always gotten the pain in here and when
i was in uh i was so scared when we were
starting to film uh space
right before it much like right before a
date with markiplier i hurt my back
i don't know how or why but before we
filmed the date with mark well i know
how then i was doing like these uh
insanity workouts and i was just doing
them hardcore and then i was doing one
of them without truly controlling how i
moved my body and pop something went pop
in my back and i'm pretty sure it's like
the same spot that's been bothering me
ever since uh so that hurt and then
right before we started filming space
you know i go rock climbing just just
just to see what it's like again because
i hadn't gone rock climbing in forever
you know i was i was so safe masked up
and everything i was climbing those
rocks i was so happy and then ouchies in
my back i heard it again i thought i
wasn't gonna be able to film
space that's how bad it hurt i literally
when i got horizontal on a sofa i
couldn't get up i couldn't
i i physically it took me 30 seconds to
get up you don't feel old until it takes
you 30 seconds to get up but this one
was an injury this one on my back now
that's just that's just i think that
one's just like my back is failing me
but uh i'm okay it's fine it's just it's
just a little like pulled muscle or
something like that
yeah i'm not too worried about it but it
if you don't listen to distractible
through the convenient link in the
description below
i'll never heal
my my my back
pain threshold goes up and down based on
how many people are tuning in
can't believe it
mark knows how to live i don't know
about that i don't i don't know about
that i don't know about that i i oh
actually this is something i talked
about on distractible i had a complete
life revelation just a few weeks ago not
joking not exaggerating i realized
something that i've been doing wrong my
entire life
that i only up until this point
have discovered that i was doing wrong
and you know you know you'd think that
would be some trivial thing like oh you
know i was walking my my feet a little
in or out or whatever my ankles are all
funky and you know whatever like i was i
did math wrong no
i
learned how to eat properly
three weeks
ago i'm not talking diet i'm not talking
to any of that i'm not talking like oh
eat the right things no i learned how to
chew
three weeks ago
i'm not joking about that i'm not
exaggerating on lady dimitrescu's honor
i swear i learned how to chew three
weeks ago
i
literally i am not exaggerating i
was looking up some stuff about like
eating and something said like okay
savor the food that you eat and i was
like okay i'll savor the food that i eat
and you know because i don't usually do
that and i've known that i don't usually
do that but i thought i i thought i
chewed things i really did i thought i
tasted food i really did
turns out
i was completely wrong
from my entire life i have been
consuming food incorrectly
and
i did this i discovered this because i
got
blueberries i had a cup of blueberries
one cup exactly one cup and i was like
okay i'm gonna savor these blueberries
i'm really gonna taste the flavor of the
blueberries i popped some blueberries in
my mouth i chewed them a long time lo
and behold like little sparks of flavor
shot up into my brain i talked about
this on distractible for you guys listen
to it but i'll explain more i like
little sparks of flavor shot up into my
brain and i was just like oh wow
that's really incredible that's very
good and i spent like 15 minutes eating
this cup of blueberries i was going like
one two at a time which i don't go one
two at a time of anything i shovel it in
and so i was like wow that was the best
cup of blueberries i've ever had when i
have lunch i'm going to really savor it
because i really want to appreciate the
food that i'm eating i want to go out
there and i want to really enjoy it and
i knew what i was going to get i was
going to get chipotle and i was just
like okay i know chipotle i love
chipotle i'll just go get chipotle and
i'll get a burrito and i'll just really
savor it and so lo and behold i get my
burrito
i get in my car
i start munching away i take one bite
and i'm like i'm really gonna savor this
i'm really gonna savor this
and after like 30 seconds of chewing i
was like
this tastes like cardboard
this tastes like cardboard i was like
okay i had a burrito so maybe the
tortilla was a little bland i got to get
into the ingredients no i kept chewing
and i spent like 20 minutes on these
bites i i chewed and chewed
and it tasted like cardboard
i got a third of the way through the
burrito before i stopped because i
didn't like what i was eating and that's
never happened in my life before in my
life
well maybe it's happened but you know
that doesn't usually happen to me for
something that i enjoy i actually chewed
it
and i actually tasted it
and i
i didn't like it
and i couldn't believe it
i was floored i was stunned there was no
way
in hell that this could be true because
the only conclusion that i could come to
is that i had not actually been tasting
chipotle
and so i tried it with more foods i
tried it with other things i tried it
with strawberries loved those i had my
salad and i had a steak mac and cheese
didn't like it
i tried cheese
i
um i'm crashing again they're taking
away my internet because i'm revealing
the secrets of the
universe oh there goes no come back
no
hello
could i please stream
hello i'm back now they're they're
trying to shut me down because i'm
revealing truth of the universe gosh
pay attention i'm back now all right so
where was i yeah i tried other foods i
tried cheese i didn't like it i tried
mac and cheese i didn't like it
there's so many different foods that i i
thought i didn't like egg yolks
tried egg yolks actually tasted the
flavor i liked it
couldn't believe it my entire palate is
changing because i had never actually
been tasting food and throughout my
entire life i've chased
i have chased
sharp flavors really salty things really
spicy things really sour things you guys
probably know this about me i really
love spicy sour and like intense flavors
and that's because there's no time for
anything to actually hit my tongue
because i am downing it so quickly i'm
like a snake unhinging my jaw and
getting whatever spicy sour salty food i
can in my mouth
and i realize like this harkens back all
the way to when i was a kid
when i was a kid i challenged myself to
swallow everything possible whole
i i like the only thing i really
remember from back then was that i i ate
chef boyardee mini ravioli specifically
the mini ones because i could swallow
them multiple at a time i didn't want to
swallow the big ones because it hurts it
hurts
and i got to three mini raviolis at a
time and that's how i was as a kid i
never actually chewed anything and i i
realized like throughout my entire life
i have really not been chewing anything
because it has been breaking a habit of
trying to swallow something as soon as
it goes in my mouth with me actually
trying to taste things
i ate at a really fancy restaurant i had
wagyu
supposedly an extremely tasty cut of
meat that when i ate it i was like
that's no better than any other steak
because i didn't actually taste it
anyway
yeah and that's that is why i love takis
powder because it's such an intense
flavor it's not even like a flavor it's
just like something punching me in the
tongue
and that's what i've always craved and
i've always chased like the feeling of
being full because i never got any
satisfaction about anything that i eat
that's really sad when you think about
it it's just really sad
i've really i i have chewed food don't
get me wrong i've chewed some things but
i never chewed things enough
i never chewed things enough i have i
have not chewed things nearly to the
point where they need to be chewed or to
even appreciate them
it's so sad
but also now i'm kind of like
re-experiencing life i'm kind of like
re-experiencing eating and i'm like able
to actually appreciate foods now which
totally changes my palate and totally
changes like my cravings for food it's
so
insane to think about it's not that i
still it's not that i don't like intense
flavors i still like hot sauce on things
and i still like sour things but i don't
chase them because there are also other
flavors that are intense if you actually
give them a chance to be tasted in your
mouth by chewing them properly and
letting the saliva dissolve it with
their enzymes
yeah
i guess i didn't appreciate amy's
last supper you have a point there i i
guess i get i don't know you know what i
don't know
i don't know
i have to do mindful eating yeah that's
the thing i just chew the takis no
i can't
oh man yeah no who knows what that's
been doing to my body who knows what
that's been doing to my body my whole
life
who knows
anyway i'm uh i'm i'm a changed man now
i'm a changed man
that's the thing that's the thing like i
i've noticed my jaw
hurts when i eat now because i'm chewing
so much more than i have and i'm like oh
no my underdeveloped chewy muscles oh no
oh god why
so like but but expect me just in like a
few months after i've
resolved this my just jaw just like has
grown out to this size because i've been
making do with these tiny
baby-like chewing muscles you know
really
step one get food
look it's uh
it's it's a wild life it's a wildlife
and i have so much to complain about i
have so much to complain about i've got
something else to complain about i got
something else to absolutely complain
about it's it's totally not a problem
that a lot of people could relate to but
it just like it's just such a
frustrating experience uh because
recently i've been trying to change my
adhd medication uh from adderall to this
new one called the stars and
i've never
hated
insurance more in my life than at this
moment i i got i got a prescription two
months ago it has not been filled
and i
like i can't even i can't even i can't
even understand the process behind this
like if any of you have dealt with
insurance with like a like a
prescription or something like that
how
how can they
decide
not
to do something
that because they believe that you don't
need it it's just like it's such a
strange thing because like when i when i
you know you get a prescription you're
just like i got a prescription you fill
it out in a pharmacy it's your job i
hand this to you the i went to the
doctor and get to the to the thing and
then the insurance company is like hey
you need a you need a uh written letter
from your doctor uh telling you that you
telling us that you need this medicine
and i'm just like
that is his signature is right on the
thing here it says this guy needs this
medicine isn't that what you're looking
for nah
nah nah nah
nah nah nah nah nah nah nah so you have
to go i went through like a three week
process of just trying to be like
yeah yes
yes he wrote the prescription so
he says i need it so that's that's my
doctor you know i don't know you don't
know him because that's not your
business but anyway and then the the
other the other frustrating thing is
like it's still not filled because i
eventually got through with the
insurance thing but i went to cvs of all
places i went to cvs and i was like hey
can you fill this and like it's a new
medication so they were like oh yeah i
guess we'll have to order it and then
the next week they were like ah i didn't
come in
and i'm like
why and they're like i don't know
and literally that was all they gave me
they were just like
i don't know and so i was like can you
can you try again is it like sold out or
something and they're like i don't know
so like yeah we'll try again and they
ordered it again and then they came back
and they were just like that didn't come
in
and i was like
why i don't know and it was a different
person saying i don't know it's like
such it's such a strange thing and then
finally what happened was i had them
order it again and it didn't come in so
i came in to the store and i was like
please somebody i'm begging you i just
need information of why no one will tell
me why and so they were they were
literally just like
oh yeah yeah yeah no one's uh that's
that's new so uh our wholesaler doesn't
stock that and i'm like
then why don't you order it why why
don't you why don't you order it and
they're like oh because it's new and not
enough people
and i was just like
well i'm here
anyway it's just like it's it's like the
strangest most frustrating thing that's
been like the side story to my entire
life is because like i i just i just
like
i was
i just wanted this prescription
and it's just impossible for anything to
be done anyway it's it's i don't know if
that's relatable to anybody but it's
just been like some [ __ ] mind-numbing
thing where they they don't believe you
number one and then they don't provide
you with any information or they just
don't know and then there's this
horrible feedback loop where you just if
you're if you're not in the in you just
can't get any help and it's just like oh
okay i guess not and to this day my
prescription is not fulfilled so
whatever it's fine anyway
whatever that's another complaint
entirely
where's the late god is new people in
here that haven't seen this it's on the
thumbnail lady democracy is right here
hi
hi there
hello
i i i don't want anyone to get the wrong
idea like this is only the way that i
have to hold it her hit it her
because it's just so huge just
absolutely massive for those of you who
don't know this is a gift from alex tema
he gave this
uh to me for some unknown reason so go
tell him thank you
because
well don't say thank you because that
would imply that i'm
grateful for it which i am not
maybe
i don't know a
true floppy neck
you know
not doing too good i'm doing too good
but yeah no lady uh lady dammit rescue
is huge
oh
wait i wonder if i can just
yeah there we go easy peasy easy
hold
hello help
hi hello again hi how are you doing i'm
back now
everybody
i don't know why that's been happening i
have no idea anyway
uh there's probably yes i'm back hello
hi yes hold good you held i'm glad thank
you so much for holding um there's other
there's many other things that i've been
uh up to these days
um
but a lot of them i'm just gonna kind of
keep to myself for the most part just
because it's better uh that way because
i'm not ready to share some of them with
you just yet but i'm i i'll let you know
that i'm
i'm
i'm pursuing something very interesting
to me again that's something i've done
before but it's just like i've found
like this renewed uh
idea behind it and so i'm really really
hitting it hard i'm spending like pretty
much all my free time doing that um and
it's just like it's kind of consuming me
at the moment because my day-to-day is
filled so much with the other stuff that
i have to do just like normal videos um
the feedback on all the other projects
but then like it's always important to
carve out some personal time for the
thing that you really like and there's
something that i'm i'm working on it's
going to take me a long long time
obviously it still is but just like
very very excited about it
what's up with space uh it is currently
being worked on you know post production
takes a lot of time for that uh but you
guys will see it in the near future i
will let you more know more when i am
ready to let you know more
um and it's just
it's something uh
yeah it's something that i like
i'm excited about but again i'm not
ready to talk about because
i need to actually do the thing before i
actually do it and it's not it's not a
it's not a video thing it's kind of like
a thing for me and that's kind of nice
to have i haven't really been doing a
lot of uh social media for a while now
not that i regret that i don't mind that
at all i'm actually perfectly okay with
not doing social media stuff like
updating on twitter or instagram or
whatever i'll do it when i have
something to share but just like
i've just been
it's been kind of nice just doing things
for me um also because i'm so busy like
i'm incredibly busy um but also just
like it's been nice but
i also feel like i've been a little
disconnected with you guys i i don't
like that feeling especially when it
comes to me making a lot of stuff that i
want to show you it's like there's only
so many things that i can keep hidden
before they actually come out uh but i
don't want it to be just like a constant
thing where i'm always hiding something
because i'm not ready to show it i i
kind of miss
um doing stuff like this where i just
like chat with people and i know for the
members out there thank you guys so much
i i know i haven't done a member mixer
in a while i i really want to get back
into the swing of things it's like when
you fall out of a habit it just like
goes away i i thought habits would stick
a little harder but you know with all
the stuff that i was doing and the
things that got in the way it's been
it's been difficult oh yeah no i have no
regrets about being away from social
media i'm not saying like oh i wish i
was a little more active like no no no
but i do want to be a little bit more
connected you know i think that um
i think that it's easy to
take that stuff for granted and and it
you know admittedly i'm trying to make
things that i think you guys are going
to love and i think you guys are going
to really enjoy but also at the same
time like there's there's deep meaning
in a lot of things that like i want to
do or at least i hope there's meaning
and a lot of things that i want to do um
and so
like just just
boiling everything down to what the next
big project is going to be isn't the
most sustainable way to live um but when
it comes down to just like the
connection you know the whole reason
that i started youtube and
or at least continued with youtube after
the beginning was because of that
connection i felt with you guys and
having you guys enjoy what i made and
seeing what you guys were talking about
and you know seeing the stuff that you
made like because it was inspired by it
like it's that's that's really beautiful
part of all this
it's always been at the forefront of my
mind but it's like sometimes you gotta
just like say things you gotta talk
about it and you gotta actually get
those feelings out and in the open so
that you can
i don't know
acknowledge that they're true you know
just because you're talking to yourself
about feelings you know me talking into
a camera but i'm talking to you guys
just like sometimes just saying it out
loud is all you really need to know
what the truth is you know so
i'm very happy to
be able to do the things that i want to
do i know i'm busy but you know that's
only gotten me better at time management
than anything so i'm able to tackle it i
haven't broken yet except my back don't
know why i haven't broken my back but my
back hurts a little bit but just like
i haven't had a chance to thank you guys
yet
for a while i have no chance to thank
you for
being a part of this
channel and being a part of just like
this
weird road that i'm taking you all on
and i can't believe people are still
following me i feel like sometimes i
feel like forrest gump just running and
there's people that just start following
me behind and they're like like why do
you do what you do and why do you make
videos do you make it i was like
i just like making things
but it is nice it is nice to know that
people are willing to uh
see where the road is gonna be but let
me run ahead so that if i just like if
the road leads off like a cliff's edge
and i just go plummeting at least you're
gonna see me plummet so maybe that's why
you guys are all still here watching
yeah but it's just uh yeah it's good
i really appreciate it i really do
i'm so grateful for
every chance that i have
and uh
yeah so grateful for you
yeah
i think i actually covered everything i
i didn't have a lot of time because i
got some other stuff that i need to do
tonight and also i'm gonna go lay down
with my back my stupid back um but yeah
just thank you guys so much for being
here and thank you for
i don't know believe it
thank you that's very nice of you
and i hope to repay that belief with uh
some good delicious
content
i've got some spicy content cooking up
in the content ovens you guys are gonna
you guys are gonna love it you guys are
gonna love this content it's gonna be
good
yeah so look forward to some cool stuff
coming very soon and i'm gonna get out
of here before i my internet crashes
again but thank you guys
thank you thank you thank you i can't
thank you enough and i'll try to
have a nice day have a nice saturday
i'll see you at midnight and uh have a
lovely time
bye
farewell goodbye
goodbye farewell